[Music]  in the car put your hand do not touch  that gun  keep your hand put your hands up  get your hands on the feet  put your hands up now front passenger  put your hands up  don't move just keep your hands up  i see it  yep yep  hey  guys you're in the front seat put your  hands up  keep him up put him out of the window  there we got a single zero right here on  my side on your side yeah who has it  front or back  back to right  unlock the doors unlock the doors  this guy's got a gun right here  hey you hear me i'm gonna open this door  you keep your hands out the window  and do not fuck  hey  [Music]  you now  shots fired shots fired shots fired  [Applause]  oh  you